en
ben ali candidat
bâle ots le week end du rituel le cadre
surnommé vapeur avec m
au fond il y en a un qui ne va pas
m
le colonel
ainsi
d
à deux mois
ouais bah
ça
bonsoir à tous ça me rassure vous êtes
vivant vous avez survécu alors peu
importe si vous avez tenu dix secondes
20 secondes 30 secondes une minute le
but de cette expérience s'était pas de
tenter de battre votre record personnel
ce soir le but c'était d'essayer de
vivre une petite parenthèse un moment
suspendu où le temps s'arrête dans le
silence dans l'immobilité dans un
environnement qui est unique
exceptionnel et surtout tous ensemble
collectivement et c'était je crois une
très belle expérience
ce sont des moments assez rare dans nos
sociétés d'aujourd'hui parce qu'on vit
dans une société où les maîtres mots
c'est l'urgence c'est la vitesse c'est
la communication c'est l'information
c'est l'instantanéité
tout va très très vite on est toujours
sollicité par nos téléphones ordinateurs
nos tablettes les réseaux sociaux la
télé la radio les panneaux publicitaires
les coups de fil les sms les mails et
cetera et cetera ses incessants et donc
du coup on n'a jamais de moment au calme
au repos pour laisser un peu notre
mental donc c'est toutes nos pensées
un petit peu de répit on n'a jamais il
faut savoir que sur le long terme un
mental qui en hyper activité en
permanence bah c'est pas bon ça crée de
la fatigue fatigue nerveuse physique
qu'il vient chronique
ça crée beaucoup de stress on a tous
entendu parler de ce fameux burn out qui
nous guette tous et ben moi ma thérapie
pour échapper à cette frénésie masse et
l'apnée alors l'apnée je pratique en
compétition pour faire des records
j'explore le monde
pour plonger dans les plus beaux
endroits du monde mais depuis quelques
années j'utilise aussi l'apnée comme une
forme d' hygiène de vie
c'est devenu un mode de vie une
philosophie et c'est une manière pour
moi d'avoir une meilleure santé physique
une meilleure santé mentale ça apporte
disons beaucoup de bien-être alors je
sais que cette idée de bien-être elle
n'a pas forcément été évident pour vous
tout à l'heure quand on a fait le petit
test c'était pas évident de se détendre
et d'avoir et va avoir du bien-être
parce que vous êtes assis ça fait
quelques heures que vous êtes assis on
n'est pas dans l'eau c'est beaucoup plus
facile de se détendre quand on est dans
l'eau et puis en plus de ça l'idée de
faire de l'apnée vous avez beaucoup d'à
priori
parce que faire de l'apnée s'arrêter de
respirer et arrêter de respirer c'est un
petit peu arrêter de vivre et donc du
coup pour chacun d'entre vous je sais
que ça fait remonter des choses ancré
très profondément depuis l'enfance cette
idée que faire de la place et suffoquer
c'est panique et c'est très anxiogène
voilà c'est ce que je vais essayer de
faire danser quelques minutes s'est
essayé de balayer tout ça et vous
montrer que la pratique de l'apnée
arrêté de respirer et apprendre à
respirer ça peut être quelque chose
d'extraordinaire pour le corps humain et
pour votre mental et on peut se nourrir
énormément de ce type d'expérience mais
d'abord je vous amener d'abord dans
l'univers de la respiration puisque
avant de faire une apnée forcément il
faut bien respirer mais j'étais assis
sur ma chaise j'ai ventilé calmement la
respiration
vous êtes en train de respirer la peau
vous m'écoutez ça paraît tellement
évidemment c'est tellement banal
on est sur un premier cri un jour on
m'aura le plus tard possible j'espère
sur un dernier souffle
et puis entre les deux on va passer
d'une rive vie à respirer une vie
entière à respirer de manière totalement
inconsciente et ben moi j'utilise la
respiration comme une baguette magique
et grâce à la respiration j'arrive à
modifier des états de conscience
j'arrive à modifier mes émotions mon
mental et aussi la façon dont réagit mon
corps
donc je pourrais faire une heure sur la
respiration mais je vais essayer de vous
donner 3 3 petits trucs trois petits
points sur lesquels moi je me concentre
avant de plonger très profond la
première chose c'est au niveau de
l'inspiration au niveau de l'inspiration
je vous ai bien regarder tout à l'heure
quand il y avait écrit respirer
profondément et je vous ai tous vus
faire la même erreur
c'est à dire que vous avez tous respirer
avec la partie haute des poumons ce
qu'on appelle la respiration thoracique
mais c'est ça alors que nous sommes
dotés d'un muscle extraordinaire qu'on
appelle le diaphragme et qu'on pourrait
utiliser la respiration diaphragmatique
avec le diaphragme donc et le muscle
principal de la respiration qui va
tapisser le fond de la cage thoracique
qui va séparer l'abdomen de la cage
thoracique en contractant ce diaphragme
on va permettre à toute la colonne d'air
de rentrée on va rentrer toute la partie
on va remplir toute la partie basse des
poumons et on va assurer un remplissage
maximal sans aucune tension une
respiration sur le long terme qui se
fait avec le haut de la cage thoracique
avec la nuque avec le sternum
avec toute cette partie là sur le long
terme ça crée beaucoup de tensions s'est
tous entendu parler du mal de dos le mal
de nuque
vous savez tous que si je viens entre
voulais je viens vous masser la nuque je
vais pas le faire désolé mais si jamais
je venais vous masser la nuque
je verrai beaucoup de tension et tout ça
c'est lié à une mauvaise respiration
donc apprendre à respirer avec le
diaphragme a inspiré avec le diaphragme
ça permet déjà d'évacuer beaucoup de
tension et surtout ça permet d'oxygéner
lors le corps est l'organisme un maximum
respirer que le diaphragme ça ressemble
à ça peut mettre une main ici et une
main là et il ya que la main sur le
ventre qui te bouger
et dans la vie de tous les jours
là vous devrez y respirer qu'avec le
diaphragme deuxième point important à la
fin de l'inspiration
il faut ne faut pas se précipiter à
vouloir explorer tout de suite à la fin
de l'inspiration moi j'essaye à chaque
fois de faire une petite rétention d'air
une rétention d'air c'est pas une apnée
parce que ça dure cinq secondes 10
secondes 15 secondes maximum et en
faisant cette petite rétention d'air
je vais arriver à modifier l'activité
cérébrale mon activité cérébrale faut
savoir que l'actrice y est l'activité
cérébrale peut être enregistrée avec un
électroencéphalogramme on peut voir les
ondes donc qui montre l'activité
électrique et les ondes en différentes
fréquences là vous êtes en train de
m'écouter vous êtes attentif
majoritairement il y à des ondes bêta
dès que vous arrêter de respirer ne
serait ce que quelques secondes
automatiquement vous allez diminuer la
fréquence de ces ondes cérébrales donc
diminue l'activité cérébrale et on aura
une prépondérance des ondes alpha est
instantanément
on va avoir un état de bien-être et un
état de calme c'est magique c'est tout
simple on peut le faire là
instantanément troisième chose
ultra important peut-être même le plus
important c'est l'expiration
j'essaye toujours d'avoir un contrôle de
mon expiration j'essaye que l'expiration
soit la plus longue possible pour la
faire durer longtemps
je vais juste fermé mal assortis je vais
diminuer le débit
ça ressemble à ça
bon je vais pas aller jusqu'au bout on a
pour une minute encore mais ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que en juste un peu
en mettant notre perception sur la sueur
sur la manière d'explorer en expirant le
plus longtemps possible
on va aboutir à un état de calme de
l'organisme pourquoi parce qu une
expiration contrôler va stimuler le nerf
vague qui va du coup activer le système
parasympathique responsables d'eux on va
dire de de calmer l'organisme est de
ralentir l'activité cardiaque quand on
expire lentement le coeur ralentit et
donc avant de partir pour m'ont amené
avec ces trois points essentiels je suis
dans les meilleures dispositions mais là
ce qui est intéressant ce que je me
souvienne n'avaient pas tous devenir
happiness du jour au lendemain mais par
contre utiliser la respiration dans la
vie de tous les jours pour en un clin
d'oeil atteindre un état de relaxation
quand vous êtes dans un état de stress
ça ça c'est super important
moi dans la vie de tous les jours
j'utilise tout le temps cette petite
technique de respiration avant de
rentrer sur scène je peux vous dire que
je faisais pas le fier et grâce à la
respiration
j'ai pu m'appeler et totalement
maintenant que mon corps et mon mental
sont prêts je peux commencer l'année
donc pour commencer mon année je vais
faire une inspiration comble est donc là
cette fois ci je peux me permettre
d'utiliser et le diaphragme puis ensuite
la cage thoracique mais dans l'ordre
d'abord le diaphragme puis ensuite la
cage thoracique c'est comme une
bouteille d'eau on vous l'a remplie
s'est remplie d'abord le bas puis en sus
le haut
et là je commence là et quand je
commence mon harnais finalement le fait
d'arrêter de respirer
c'est comme si je fermais la dernière la
dernière voie de communication avec le
monde extérieur
le fait de fermer la bouche et de couper
toute circulation d'air je me retrouve
avec moi même généralement je fais ça
dans l'eau et là c'est encore plus fort
dans l'eau je me retrouve totalement
englobé par l'élément liquide je suis
dans un autre univers
mais ça peut être un peu friand quand on
avait un vélo quand on n'a pas
l'habitude parce qu'à ce moment là je me
retrouve en tête à tête avec moi même je
me retrouve seul face à face sans aucune
source de distraction est ce que c'est
ça le monde dans lequel on vit c'est un
monde qui remplit de distraction tout le
temps on est tout le temps ouvert sur
l'extérieur et qu'ils sont bons ces
moments où on arrête en couple sont en
couple images et on se retrouve seul
avec soi-même
il ya un état immense de relaxation qui
arrive ce qui est fantastique c'est que
le corps nous accompagnent dans cette
expérience c'est à dire que sans rien
pour lui demande de faire le fait de se
mettre en apnée vous allez avoir le
rythme cardiaque qui va diminuer encore
plus cette année un réflexe on appelle
le réflexe d'immersion qui intervient
même si on s'immerge pas dès que l'on
arrête de respirer c'est un mécanisme de
protection du corps pour préserver
l'oxygène donc le métabolisme au ralenti
et je me mets un peu en hibernation et
là je peux pas m'enfuir
je peux pas me cacher je suis dans une
relation très intime et dans un face à
face avec moi même et c'est un peu comme
si je faisais pour la première fois
connaissance avec qui j'étais
notre vie de tous les jours les deux
verbes qu'on utilise le plus souvent et
qui caractérise notre comportement c'est
le faire on est toujours dans l'action
et avoir toujours dans la quête de la
possession
et quand je me mets en apnée quand
j'arrête de respirer c'est un autre
verbe qui prend le relais c'est
à ce moment là j'ai l'impression
vraiment pleinement d'être et cette
expérience là elle paraît comme ça
complètement surnaturel peut-être vous y
tenez complètement timbrés celui-là
c'est normal c'est un champion du monde
etc
mais c'est ça que j'ai envie de vous les
faire passer comme message finalement
c'est que il ya rien de plus simple que
d'apprendre à respirer à maîtriser votre
respiration et ya rien de plus simple
que de retenir ne serait ce que quelques
secondes sa respiration calmement ça
peut se faire dans son lit ça peut se
faire dans l'eau il ya des clubs
d'amener partout en france maintenant à
paris d'avoir une dizaine de clubs
d'amener et je vous garantis que
l'expérience de l'apprentissage de la
respiration et à prendre un arrêté de
respirer ça va vous apporter énormément
de choses énormément une chose pour
votre santé physique émotionnel mental
j'ai mis quelques mots clés ou là pour
vraiment résumé tout ce que la
respiration et l'arrêt de la respiration
vous pouvoir vous procurer un état de
calme le silence la sérénité une
meilleure capacité à se concentrer une
connexion une harmonie avec vous même et
avec l'environnement qui est autour de
vous et également beaucoup d'énergie
énormément d'énergie
vous allez pouvoir utiliser pour mieux
vivre au quotidien
alors si j'ai un mot à vous faire passer
pour finir c'est n'ayez pas peur en
faisant de l'apnée vous n'allez pas
suffoquer
vous allez pas vous étouffez vous allez
juste basculer dans une autre dimension
et vivre des expériences personnelles et
intimes extraordinaire merci à vous